problema número 12 tenemos que resolver
esta operación bueno vamos a desarrollar
la 0.1 se queda igual 0.1 al cuadrado es
0.01 más punto uno al cubo es 0.001
ahora lo sumamos nos va a quedar 0.1 1-1
que es nuestra opción ve muy bien
asegúrense de multiplicar sus decimales
y si tienen problemas con decimales vean
los vídeos relacionados en el canal de
khan academy que cubren la aritmética
básica ahora veamos el siguiente
problema
un carpintero construyó una caja de
arena rectangular con una capacidad de
10 metros cúbicos si el carpintero
construyera otra caja similar del doble
de largo y el doble de ancho y el doble
de alto cuál será la capacidad de metros
cúbicos de la segunda caja de red
bueno aquí quisiera visualizar qué es lo
que nos están planteando y la mejor
manera de ver cuántas veces cabe la
primera caja de la segunda caja es
dibujar lo voy a dibujar en verde más o
menos la caja original la primera caja
más o menos así
más o menos así ok ahora voy a dibujar
la segunda caja que es el doble de ancho
que se dibuja la otra cajita igual a la
otra a la primera cajita el doble de
alto entonces aquí voy a dibujar más o
menos
estas otras cajitas ustedes disculpen si
no me salen así como que muy precisas
pero a veces no es fácil dibujar así a
mano alzada y el doble de largo así que
hay otra cajita aquí
otra cajita aquí atrás
sin otra aquí y así
más o menos en línea punteada voy a
poner los que estas líneas interiores
más o menos ok
bueno ahí está más o menos la idea así
que cuántas de las cajas originales
caben en la nueva caja que es lo que nos
preguntan bueno 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 que es
lo mismo que expresar lo
como 2 el doble de ancho el doble de
alto y el doble de largo si es que por
ejemplo tomamos nuestra primera caja
como una unidad y esto va a ser igual a
8 cajas originales y nos dicen que la
capacidad de la caja original es de 10
metros cúbicos así que multiplicamos 8
por 10 metros cúbicos y es igual a 80
metros cúbicos
y esta es nuestra opción de
muy bien ahora veamos el siguiente
problema cuadra los siguientes no pueden
ser un valor de 1 entre x 1
en esta ocasión nos conviene revisar las
opciones que nos dan nos dicen que la
opción a es menos 1
si x fuera 0 esto nos debe como
resultado menos 1 y como nos piden algo
que no puede ser un resultado o un valor
de esto pues la opción a no es veamos la
opción ver la opción b nos dice 0 ok
esta si es una opción válida porque de
ninguna manera no importa qué valor le
ponga yo aquí al x esta fracción nunca
me va a dar ser la única forma de
acercarnos es que esa fracción fuera muy
muy pequeña y eso sólo se logra teniendo
una x muy grande pero aún así aunque
tuviéramos una x enorme aquí esto nunca
alcanzaría hacer ser así que mi
respuesta correcta es la b veamos el
problema 15
una panadería con una provisión diaria
de 40 docenas de roles la mitad de los
roles se venden antes del mediodía y el
80% de los roles restantes se venden
entre el mediodía y la hora del cierre
cuantas docenas de roles no se vendieron
al final del día bueno vamos a anotar
los datos que nos dan es la mitad
de estas 40 docenas se venden
antes
mediodía
yo creo todo mundo la aspira para
desayunar yo el 80% restante
tanto
se vende en 3
mediodía
ahora
el cierre
ok entonces la mitad de 40 son 20
docenas que estaban vendidas
al mediodía o antes del mediodía
del mediodía
y estos son los 20 restantes de inter
restantes que a estos le tenemos que
sacar el 80 por ciento
restantes
entonces podemos los sombreros de dos
maneras una es decir bueno el 20% de lo
que resta no será vendido así que
multiplicamos 20 perdón un 0.20 por 20 y
eso nos dará 20 por 20 son 400 y 2
lugares desde el punto decimal
eso es igual a 44 docenas
no se vende 80 de estos 22 en las
restantes el 80% va a ser 0.80 por 20
que es igual a mí
600 luego tenemos 2 recorremos dos
lugares el punto decimal 16 y esto nos
queda 16 16 que son las que se venden
entre mediodía y la hora del cierre a 20
le restamos 16 y nos queda que las que
no se venden son 42 cenas
esto llamamos tiempo pero da el mismo
resultado aunque al resolver exámenes
uno debe enfocarse en resolverlos de
manera rápida y bien vemos el problema
cuál es el área combinada en centímetros
cuadrados de la parte de enfrente y de
atrás de un pedazo rectangular de papel
que mide ocho y medio por once once
centímetros por cierto no lo puse pero
son centímetros ya que estamos hablando
de centímetros cuadrados ok entonces
pues vamos a calcular el área de uno de
los lados y como queremos ver el área de
delante y detrás pues va a ser
multiplicar esa área por dos entonces va
a ser 2 x
ocho y medio
por 11 que esto es igual 8 por 2 16 2
por un medio es una 16 más uno son 17
por 11 vamos a hacer aquí 17 por 11
1717 sumamos 781 esto es igual a 187
centímetros cuadrados que es nuestra
opción
ok problema número 17 150 es qué
porcentaje de 30 bueno vamos a expresar
lo aquí en 150 es igual a equis un
porcentaje por 30 diremos a ambos lados
entre 30 y nos va a quedar que esto
entre 30
esto entre 30 x es igual 150 entre 30 es
igual a 15 entre 3 que es igual a 5
y si queremos tener esto como un
porcentaje vamos a multiplicar ambos
lados por 100 así que podemos decir que
x es igual
a 500 por ciento lo cual tiene sentido
si 30 es el 100% 60 será el 200% 90 será
el 300% 120 será 400 por ciento y 150
será el 500 por ciento que es nuestra
opción
y de nuevo muy bien veamos el siguiente
problema el número 18
la proporción 2 a un tercio es igual a
esto nos pasamos de esta manera
proporción 2a
un tercio esto es igual a 2 por 3 entre
que es igual 2 por 36 entre 1 que es la
proporción 6 a 1
esta es nuestra opción y el siguiente
problema número 19 corriendo una misma
razón constante 6 máquinas idénticas
producen un total de 270 botellas por
minuto a esta razón cuántas botellas
podrían producir 10 máquinas iguales en
4 minutos
bueno vamos a ver cuánto produce cada
una de estas máquinas sin seis máquinas
producen 270 botellas
un minuto por minuto entonces una
máquina va a producir esto en 36 una
máquina va a producir 270 botellas por
minuto en 36 así que 10 máquinas
diez máquinas van a producir esto por
diez
son 270 36 x 10 así que va a ser igual a
2700 entre 6 botellas por minuto y para
saber cuánto producen estas máquinas en
4 minutos vamos a tener que multiplicar
esto por 4 esto por 4 y nos da
700 por 4 entre 6
esto es lo mismo
2700 por 4 entre dos por tres
dos mil 733 es 900 y 3 entre 3 es uno
así que nos queda que es igual
900 por 4 entre 24 entre 22 nos queda
900 por 2 es igual a 1.800 botellas
botellas
que es nuestra opción y con esto
terminamos los problemas de este vídeo